17h12
ce pur et
il vi davis donne des coups de marteau
un chantier grandeur nature pour ses
quinze élèves qui construisent aussi du
mobilier comme ses tabourets et qui
prennent du plaisir
pétole
on fait des activités sur leur faim - 5
places
moi je me plais bien ici là c'est bien
c'est votre avis dans le fret où c'est
très intéressant c'est encourageant
c'est une belle expérience à 14 15 ans
ils sont on sait que pas une classe pour
des élèves présentant des difficultés
pour eux c'est l'occasion de travailler
en groupe de se confronter à la réalité
et de prendre confiance en eux en terme
d'autonomie
c'est là que les progrès sur les plus
flagrantes parce qu'ils sont sortis de
leurs dans le milieu habituel et leur
confort donc à partir de là ben voilà
faut se prendre en main sinon ça devient
très compliqué cette semaine est un
partenariat entre le camping et le
collège
d'un côté les élèves s'immerge dans un
milieu professionnel de l'autre
l'entreprise en profite pour poursuivre
des travaux débuter en 2017
le camping était à l'abandon depuis 20
ans on est content du travail des
enfants on est contents de leur rendre
service parce qu'ils peuvent sortir un
petit peu de leur quartier de leur
établissement je pense que pour les
profs c'est quelque chose aussi d'un
point de vue pédagogique sympa de
vraiment faire un lien entre ce qu'ils
apprennent dans les ateliers ou au bahut
et de le retranscrire sur le terrain
mais ces tâches mérite récompense à
quelques mètres de là où ils travaillent
ils se sont même essayés au téléski
nautique un moyen de mouiller le maillot
en s'amusant
[Musique]
et